what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to celebrity
relationships and predicting how long
they are going to last as you know
Hollywood is known for long loving
lasting relationships so I'm excited to
predict these before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell as you guys
already know if you have watched two or
more of my videos and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
also guys my goal is to get to a million
Subs before New Year's so make sure you
hit that subscribe button alright Taylor
Swift and Joe all win I I got there's a
couple things Taylor Swift has
definitely been Alpha widowed now an
alpha Widow basically means that there's
a guy okay have you ever heard that girl
talk about the ex that she hates but
she's always talking about and goes back
to that's Taylor Swift That's I mean I
don't know if she's gone back to her
exes per se because she could just be
Alpha widowed by another banging
celebrity but that's the whole point so
he's gotten her after this string of
failed relationships now how long have
they been together do you know six years
so she's 32. I'm gonna give them another
two to four and then she'll leave it
around the eight year itch yeah I'm
gonna give it two to four
I just don't see her like sticking this
one out but it could be okay all right
Beyonce is a ride or die I'm sorry if
you did a whole album on your man
cheating on you a whole album and you
stayed for that [ __ ] you're staying for
life you're there for life also I think
they're kind of cute I think she just
knows what it is she's like look it he's
gone have his side chicks but I'm gonna
go cry on our yacht because my man's a
billionaire and I just she knows what it
is she ain't leaving you think she wants
to be demoted from a billionaire
lifestyle no she can't do it Pete
Davidson and Emily ratajowski something
I don't know how to say it but I think
this is gonna last three to six months
and the reason I think that is because
let's just be honest guys P Davis and
that's a fun guy you date for a couple
of months that's not a guy you take home
to your parents respectfully Pete I'm
sorry I'm sorry but for her her
hypergamy is gonna allow her to get she
can she could pull a billionaire look
how hot she is
it's just not going to be enough for her
and she's going to break it off um three
to six months I think that Blake Lively
and Ryan Reynolds so Blake Lively red
flag did date Leonardo Dicaprio and he
just kind of seems to be like a curse of
death on his ex's relationships however
I do think she really does is into Brian
Reynolds like that I'm gonna give it how
long have they been together I think
they've been together like yeah
um I'm gonna give them 10 to 15 years
which in Hollywood relationships is a
lifetime that is a lifetime
um honestly this is an unpopular opinion
but I think Will and Jada are gonna
stick it out mostly because like with
all the stuff they've already gone
through like if he didn't divorce her
then he's never door you know what I
mean like he's never he's never leaving
she might but then again like I don't
think she's completely delusional like I
think she knows she can't do better than
Will Smith yeah they're they're sticking
it out but there's gonna be a lot of
like Rocky [ __ ] as normal but yeah and
you know what I've been saying they were
everyone loved them as a couple and I've
been saying they're a weird couple
because their kids were so weird and I
was like why why is their 16 year old in
a polyamorous relationship I don't even
know what that what that was when I was
16. um but yeah that's what happens when
you let a weird lady raise your children
Alan and Portia I think they'll stick it
out I think they'll be together how long
have they been together I don't know
anything about them he wasn't he
cheating on her oh but she cheated but
she stayed okay if she stayed past
cheating how old is she she's 38. wow
she looks great I think they'll stick it
out Haley and Justin okay I actually
think they're gonna break up I a lot of
people would disagree with me on this
but the reason I think that is because
Haley's Instagram I'm like you are
married to Justin Bieber why isn't he
all over your page I swear to God if I
was married to an international pop star
I would be flexing flexing left and
right shout out to all you girls from
high school it's like hurt her underwear
I'm like Haley you you got that you got
the man so I'm gonna give it five years
no no she's not the weird one that's the
other brother I don't know them as a
couple at all but I think they got
married in like Vegas or something and I
think he's like the Wilder brother how
old are they and how long have they been
together so he's 33 she's 26. I am going
to say they're gonna break up in two to
three years because of the body language
like he's kind of leaning into her you
know it's what do they say like she's
supposed to lean into him Hillary and
Bill they're for lifers they don't even
like each other anymore but they ain't
getting divorced they're not doing it
I'm sure she's sleeping with other dudes
I'm sure he's sleeping with other hoes
they're together forever LeBron and
Savannah I don't know there's like some
picture of LeBron like looking real
happy with the side chick right I'm
pretty sure I don't know be bad for
their brand
um they are they are
um this is a hard one because there are
some reports that I guess like she maybe
not isn't the best at home like I've
heard that but I've also I also feel
like LeBron doesn't want to get divorced
like I feel like LeBron it's just not
good for like his brand is kind of like
the family man so I I just think he has
too much and I think he would if it
wasn't for like the brand and I think
that some people the brand is more
important than the relationship like
Hillary and Bill you know so I think
they're going to stay together for the
brand oh this is a train wreck waiting
there she's gonna leave him she's gonna
leave him I thought it's crazy because
she used to be known as like the good
girl in Hollywood like you remember when
she was younger she was like oh I don't
take off my clothes everyone thought
this is how this is why I say women are
a roll of the dice women are a roll the
dice she was talking in her early 20s
she doesn't like to show her body off
like that sis then starts posing naked
at like 30. like guys are like oh you
bet her I'm like this man has known this
girl since high school he's known her
since high school he done vetted her
sometimes women we just go crazy I yeah
um this is a nightmare
um I think she'll divorce him in the
next five years and the thing is he
won't divorce her either back to Steph
Curry he won't divorce her that man he
won't divorce her she will divorce him
because him the brand is too important
His Image is too important she doesn't
give a [ __ ] you can just tell I mean
look if she's already posing naked oh no
um how long have they been together a
year I think a year maybe I give it
maybe one more Sunday is gonna leave his
ass I'm just her High part of me is
gonna get the best of her I'm sorry
Zendaya's like a sweetheart she doesn't
drink
um she she lives with her parents I'm
pretty sure like she's like oh no but
now she's doing those weird acting rules
Hollywood always ruins the sweet kids
well she's now I'll say she's naturally
sweetheart and I think a lot of like
high value men are going to be
interested in her it's not that Tom
Holland isn't a high value man he is but
I just think more high value men are
going to be interested and I think she's
gonna go for it
um at some point it's you know it's just
like yeah
um I give it six months no Adele Adele's
gonna make this [ __ ] work
um yeah she's a former fat chick
um this is like the best she can do
she's not she doesn't have like
Hollywood levels of pretty like she's
cute you know but like this this man is
her Lifeline she has a child she is not
doing better she's going to make this
[ __ ] work
um but it's still Hollywood so I give it
five to ten years five to ten years
they're already broken up so when I
slides together yeah when did you put
the slide together two days ago okay
okay I think they're gonna get married
but then I think it's gonna be like
she's definitely gonna be divorced five
years I think we need to get them down
the aisle and then three years three
years yeah but then she's gonna divorce
him let me know what you guys think in
the comments um maybe I got some right
maybe I got some wrong the only one I'm
questioning is LeBron James he looked
real happy with that side chick that man
looked like so happy with the side chick
so I don't know but I do think the brand
is important him to him but let me know
in the comments guys um like the video
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible